[Music]
without doing that numbers
[Applause]
the Warriors have answers
and Kevin's around in the open core
you don't need a tree to get a shot here
- time
I ran have been told for six on three
and then rises up to tie the game
[Applause]
we've seen this on every level with
Kevin Durant College regular season two
on the finals
[Applause]
durant on the drive tries again goes
baseline double-teamed and still gets it
a go some basketball brilliance on
display here in Game three Dancing with
the rock isolation health comes the
ability to split the defense and still
finish what a performance by Kevin
Durant second game shot clock difference
Durant
he knew he had to pull up a loop further
behind that line because of DeAndre
Jordan's reach so he pulled up to me was
it going to take any more dribbles to
trifle work it there
[Applause]
only six minutes left in the game it
comes from eight teams Alex
they've got forty sevens from JD's
absolutely dread to us Graham gets a
good-looking now is the people the rat
drives hard right a cat
direct those stutter dribble laughs is
good
drives on Harley
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know maybe 25 in the forest so 41
for Kevin snaps to tie the game patter
back out
[Applause]
and they've tied it up after being down
spin with three minutes left his 12th
career triple-double and Kevin Durant's
trapping the triple the Warriors get
again well after this shot out the shot
if Iran
[Applause]
it's the 3ds fouled
second goes to the toilet
[Applause]
this is why we love basketball Kady
didn't even have the ball in his hand
correction he wasn't even set everyone
knew he was going to shoot this ball
that's why he wants it at the is a big
one up at you boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report